ليست روسيا وحدها التي حرمت من المشاركه
في كاس العالم فهناك العديد من المنتخبات
الاخرى على مر التاريخ نذكر لكم بعضها شهد
مونديال البرازيل عام 1950 غياب كل من
منتخبات الماني الغربيه واليابان والسبب
قرار فيفا وقتها بانهم لم تكن مستقلتين
وبالتالي منعت من المشاركه وعلق الفيف
جنوب افريقيا في عام
1961 استجابه لدعوات متزايده من الحركات
المناهضه للفصل العنصري لمقاطعه جنوب
افريقيا بعد ان حضر قانون الميلاد في ذلك
الوقت الفرقه الرياضيه مختلفه الاعراب وفي
عام 2015 زعم الفيفا تدخل طرف ثالث
الاتحاد لكره القدم المحلي الاردني من قبل
الحكومه ومنع الفريق من المنافسه في
تصفيات كاس العالم 2018 و خلال مرحله
التاهل لكاس العالم روسيا 2018 منع
المنتخب الكويتي من تجربتي حظه بالتاهل
تلك النسخه وذلك بعد انتهاء المهنه كانت
منحتها الفيفا كومه من اجل تغيير قانون من
اعتبرته الاتحاد الدولي اداه لدخول
السياسه في كره القدم